Ah, subthemes. They can make your deck
better or they can make your deck worse.
And either of those two things might be
a desirable outcome depending on what
you look for in a game of Magic the
Gathering. Hi there, I'm Alex and today
I'm here to tell you about a passion of
mine, making decks do more things. Most
EDH decks will have a theme, merfolk,
tokens on attack triggers and so forth.
And this is a nice place to start in
getting a deck to do something. However,
eventually that one theme might start to
get a little boring and your eyes might
begin to wander. That on attack trigger
makes tokens. Can I play harder into
that? I really like this zombie creature
that makes me discard cards. Can I make
my deck focus more on discard? This ETB
creature searches up legendary cards. I
wonder how that might fit into my blink
deck. And this makes sense. Having your
deck do more stuff, have more textured
play paths, produce more unexpected
results, all of this will be desirable
to a lot of players, particularly
players who have already played a lot
with more linear styles of deck. So
here, I'm going to be making a little
guide on how to answer the sorts of
questions I mentioned earlier about
specific cards you're finding yourself
transfixed by. And at the end, you might
have an exciting arsenal of brand new
questions to probe your deck with. With
that said, let's begin. Assuming you're
not trying to obliterate your deck's
consistency, a good place to start in
expanding your deck's synergy universe
is going to be what I'll call fulcrum
cards. This is a thing that naturally
ties together multiple subthemes and it
can take a variety of different forms,
but typically comes in the form of a
payoff from one theme that rewards
another. Throne of Geth ties together
artifact sacrifice and counters.
Displacer Kitten ties together the
flicker and spellslinger archetypes.
Strength from the Fallen ties together
enchantments and creature stuffed
graveyards with a resulting payoff that
can work well for a power matters deck.
These are pretty clear examples of
fulcrum cards, but there are a lot of
other examples that are less obvious,
but absolutely there if you go looking.
Professional Facebreaker rewards a board
of evasive creatures with some artifact
tokens that can crack for mana.
Quicksmith Genius rewards artifacts
entering with rummages that can feed
graveyard strategies. And Squee, Dubious
Monarch rewards a stocked graveyard with
a reanimated attacker that generates
tokens. Why were all of those examples
read three times, you might ask? No
particular reason, but you should
definitely put them all in the same
deck. Regardless, all of these cards
represent points of fusion between
different archetypes, connective glue
that involves setup for one archetype
turning into payoff for another. An
important consideration when thinking
about this sort of card is the floor of
the effect. I'm stat brained, so I'd be
thinking about maybe the 25th percentile
game for a card, but basically what
we're wondering is how will the card
feel in a subpar situation when it's not
living up to our wildest dreams. For
some of the cards I mentioned earlier,
the floor is pretty high. Professional
Facebreaker will usually manage to
generate at least a couple treasures and
Displacer Kitten can at least serve as
protection even if no juicy ETB
creatures are present. For others, the
floor might be a lot lower though. Dross
Scorpion is a card I run in one of my
decks that works as a fulcrum point
between artifact creatures hitting
graveyard and tap effects, but this card
could easily end up being a poorly
stated creature with a single untap on
death and that's important to keep in
mind. It gets even worse for
non-creature permanents. In my most
recent deck review, one of my supporters
was trying to integrate a smallish
astral slide flicker package into a
deck. And unfortunately, without any
cycling cards in hand, that card is just
a three mana textless enchantment. This
is where a bit of discernment is
necessary. It's important to figure out
what works as a minor part of a deck and
what has no business being outside a
deck that doesn't heavily support it due
to its low floor. As a related example
of this, I've had a handful of people
suggest Ret to my mystic for my astral
slide deck. At first glance, this might
make sense. I'm playing a deck trying to
cycle cards, this card gives all my
creatures cycling and it's a wizard to
top it all off, grabable with either of
my wizard cycling cards. However, the
issue with adding a card like this is
that at its floor, it will always
consume a card slot that could have gone
to an ETB creature or some card draw or
a card that itself has cycling and can
replace itself. And then, how high do
you think the ceiling will be in a deck
where over 40% of the creatures already
have cycling? It looks good at first and
I'm sure it's great in a more general
graveyard deck, but once we do the floor
ceiling calculation, it becomes clear
that this little bird gets mugged by a
merfolk looter in this particular deck.
As you might have guessed, a major
factor in the floor ceiling discussion
is the amount of deck space required to
support a particular card. A lot of
possible fulcrum cards might already be
within your synergy family of choice and
might create resources that are already
useful to what you're doing even if they
theoretically might tie naturally into a
different subtheme. We can see this with
the treasure example earlier where
treasures are just a naturally useful
tool for basically all decks. This
stands in contrast to something like a
doorkeeper in an Arcades the Strategist
deck. How do you make target player
milling feel useful for a theme that
usually wins through combat damage and
doesn't traditionally utilize the
graveyard very much. I'm sure plenty of
people have done it, but it requires
more divergence from the traditional
Arcades game plan than a lot of other
defenders payoffs and will likely demand
more deck space to be any good as a
result. Another angle for thinking about
deck space could be to consider how
closely interlinked two different themes
are to one another. Sometimes there will
be a whole bunch of fulcrum cards for a
particular set of two themes with one
I've utilized in the past being
artifacts and ETB effects.
Thought Monitor, Conjurer's Closet, Myr
Battlesphere, Mimic Vat, the Mages,
there's a whole lot of options there.
And if you're playing a bunch of these,
your dual theme deck experience might
end up feeling decently compact despite
its somewhat mechanically broad nature.
However, many other sets of two themes
have dramatically less innate shared
DNA. If I'm trying to make a deck that
combines cast from exile and landfall,
well, there are two landfall cards with
exile you may play text and there are
also cards that reward playing lands
from exile in addition to casting
spells, which work well for us. And then
if we dive into from anywhere other than
your hand effects as well, we might find
some roundabout synergies in other
landfall cards such as Courser of
Kruphix and Hedron Crab among others.
Hopefully you can see what I'm getting
at here. Sometimes you're just going to
have a bit of a hard time combining two
themes. Now, does this mean that you
shouldn't smash together two very
different synergy families? No.
Artifacts plus ETB, tokens plus one one
counters, these have been done tens of
thousands of times before for good
reason, but you always have the
opportunity to do something different,
something unique, something more
specifically suited to who you are as a
player.
What you should do though is know that's
what you're doing, figure out why you're
doing that, and then figure out a plan
of action based on what your goals are.
Let's say you're building an initiative
deck with a heavy emphasis on legendary
permanents in general and the background
enchantments in particular. Cool. A bit
tricky, but there are some possible
points of connection here.
Next, it's important to figure out the
reason for building the deck because
that will affect the decisions you make.
If you're trying to build a decent
bracket three deck with this set of
restrictions as a challenge, you'll want
to dial in hard on the points of
cohesion and maybe consider ways you can
get the different elements to come
together more often. Maybe we run
partner commanders to get full use out
of Dungeon Delver and pick colors that
offer the most utility in putting
together our game plan. If we decide
that Dungeon Delver is a key card for
us, maybe we add some cards like
Enlightened Tutor, Muddle the Mixture
and a couple other helpful tutors in
whatever colors we end up in so that we
can get that card more often. And then
maybe we pair that with other useful
cards that fit the same tutoring
restrictions. If we have the goal of
getting the most mechanically fluid
version of initiative legendaries, there
are some cool decision paths we can run
down and the end result will likely be a
very unique bracket three deck. Some
people might worry that tutors will
homogenize the play experience of a
deck, but this won't necessarily be
true. Card selection tools like
filtering spells and conditional tutors
will reduce the play pattern variance of
a deck, but if you add them to a deck
that would otherwise have extreme levels
of play pattern variance due to having a
lot of moving parts, you'll likely end
up in a place that is still very fresh
and dynamic to play with. Now let's say
we're building with a different goal.
We're just trying to have a good time
and are likely aiming for a more
laid-back bracket two style deck. This
is also a very valid goal and honestly,
it's a pretty fantastic reason to make a
deck that might be a little bit
mechanically dubious. If your starting
point is a naturally slower-paced
political mechanic like initiative and
if you're introducing extra layers of
synergy rather than filling up your deck
with high quality staple creatures,
you're going to end up with something
that plays quite well at lower power
tables. You'll want to make sure you're
running enough filtering so that your
deck functions and so that you're having
fun throughout the whole process, but
the play pattern of a deck that
gradually filters for different elements
of its cool funky game plan is one that
is perfect for a bracket two game in
both pace and nature.
As a final note here, playing at a lower
power table is also a great place for a
somewhat mechanically disjointed deck
because incentives align perfectly on
what sorts of vegetables you should be
running, particularly removal. Lower
power opponents won't require all the
best removal the game has to offer and
this means that you can do something
that's already nice to do, run some of
the higher mana options with added
utility for your synergy families. My
bracket two Incubators deck has 16 cards
I've categorized as interaction, which
is a decent number, but if I click
through these on the architect page,
literally all of them do something else
for the deck. This is nice for keeping a
mechanically messy deck from feeling too
bad and it also lets me play with cards
that are a bit more unique within the
Commander format. Is Spread the Sickness
the best removal this game has to offer?
Definitely not, but it feels immensely
at home in this deck and I wouldn't dare
cut it.
Thanks for watching. I'm going to be at
Magic Con Vegas in just a week or so and
I'll be hosting a panel along with the
Trinket Mage and a couple friends of the
podcast. Come watch that or get a
sticker or just say hi, whatever floats
your boat. If you want to support what I
do here, you can grab some high quality
sleeves from Dragon Shield, affiliate
link in the description. Or you can
support me more directly through Patreon
or a YouTube membership. These lovely
people, some of whom are on screen now,
help let me keep doing what I do here
and they also receive bonus videos from
me once a month or so plus a chance at a
deck review every three months. If you
want to join this illustrious crowd, the
links and/or buttons to do so are
probably on your screen somewhere unless
something has gone horribly wrong.